bae squad fleek basic no cap
but yes turn up spilling tea
got receipts keep it a honey finesse
these are just a few
terms and phrases that originated in
black communities and have become
popularized
some might say co-opted by mainstream
american culture
but this trend predates the internet by
decades americans have long embraced
contributions to popular language from
african americans
arguably more than they've been willing
to embrace the people themselves
this cultural dissonance is just one
part of the long
complicated history of african american
english and to unpack it
i'm joined by sociolinguist and aae
researcher
dr rachel elizabeth weissler aae can go
by several different names
african-american language
african-american vernacular english
and black english ebonics was coined in
1973 by african-american psychologist
robert williams
but since then it has been co-opted by
white speakers as a derogatory term
and thus is not used by language
researchers despite the internet's
obsession with slang
aae is a lot more than a collection of
colloquialisms
it is a complete and distinct sociolect
a dialect created by social rather than
regional boundaries
it is perhaps one of the most culturally
impactful varieties of english on earth
but also the most misunderstood
other words
in 1619 the english privateership white
lion landed at point comfort in virginia
on board were 20 enslaved africans who
were traded for supplies
this transaction is of great historical
and linguistic significance
because it marks the beginning of
slavery in british colonial america
and the beginning of african-american
english the millions of people kidnapped
from africa and forced into slavery in
north america came from more than 45
distinct ethnic groups
and spoke many different languages in
most cases they couldn't communicate
with each other or their captors
but communication is necessary for
survival and in this
language contact situation the enslaved
people were forced to learn the language
of their captors
made all the more difficult by the fact
that they were not allowed to read or
write in adopting english heritage
languages were slowly lost
though some words did manage to survive
in our lexicon to this day
such as yam banjo and okra there are
several theories about the foundations
of aae
perhaps it began as a pidgin a hastily
developed form of communication between
groups that don't share a common tongue
or maybe it was the result of english
words being dropped into african grammar
systems
but the most popular theory is that it
grew out of the english dialect spoken
by white rural southerners of the time
in this region slavery and then
segregation
kept black and white communities
separated creating an environment
favorable to maintaining distinct
varieties of english
in the 20th century millions of african
americans seeking opportunities
and fleeing racial persecution relocated
to large metropolitan areas in the north
known as the great migration which is
why today aae is associated with urban
areas
there is a glaring misconception that
aae is a wrong or deficient version of
what people call mainstream american
english or
standardized american english but that
isn't the case at all
and when it comes to language views
about right
and wrong are often forms of social
prejudice
aae has its own rules of grammar usage
and pronunciation
that are as elegant and consistent as
any other dialect
and contrary to negative stereotypes
speakers of aae
are not careless with language like all
people
they are very aware of the rules of
their native dialect
and instantly know when they're broken
or misused are you sure
that you want to get turned with your
girls this weekend i promised them a
free trip and it's
turnt with a t no matter what kind of
english you speak
you're going to sound different if
you're from new york city atlanta or
philadelphia
and the regional phonetic variation in
aae reflects that
however there are some common
phonological features
th stopping where a d sound replaces a
th
so that this and that might be dis and
dat
th can also be replaced by an f or a v
so nothing and smooth
might be nothing and smooth consonant
cluster reduction
where multiple consonants at the end of
a word are simplified into one
so for example lift and test might sound
like lif
and tess the common pronunciation of ask
as
acts is an example of metathesis in
which two speech sounds are allowed in
flexible order
many english words were derived through
metathesis for example
bird and horse used to be brid and gross
several others are currently undergoing
it like nuclear
introduce and prescription in addition
to sound features
aae often differs from other types of
american english in
grammar which is fairly constant across
the country
one of the most maligned features of
aae's grammar
is the so-called double negative as in i
ain't seen nobody
but this disparagement reflects a
misunderstanding of how language works
language isn't like math where two
negatives cancel each other out
in many languages like spanish greek and
hebrew
a second negative serves to confirm or
amplify the negation
known as negative concord for instance
the spanish sentence
nobia nadier literally translates to i
didn't see nobody
even standardized american english
employs a bit of negative concord
if you want to make this sentence
negative you have to adjust the verb
and the object that anybody serves the
same function as
nobody to remind the listener that the
statement is negative
some other grammatical features of aae
include
possessive s absence instead of the
man's hat
or my momma's car you'd have the man hat
or
my mama car question word order instead
of why
aren't they going you might hear why
they ain't going
finna which etymologists trace back to
the southern phrase fix into
might replace going to organa i'm going
to go to the store
might be i'm finna go to the store zero
copula
the connecting verb to be can be removed
from sentences where they would form a
contraction
so who is that might become who dat and
she's my sister might become she my
sister
other languages like japanese and
russian also employ zero copula
for instance onodoma literally
translates to
she at home no s on third person
singular
mae changes form only for third person
singular verbs
i run you run she runs we run
they run only one s in there aae keeps
all verb forms consistent and regular
in many cases aae's verb conjugation can
actually achieve more nuance and
precision than mainstream american
english
when i say she is working i generally
mean one of two things
either she has a job or she is currently
doing work right now
in aae those are differentiated she
working
means that she is currently working at
this moment and she be working
means that she works on a regular basis
and the third option
she been working she is working and has
been for a while
now some of these features also occur in
other varieties of english
and not all of them are used by every
speaker of aae
but taken together they index aae
which means they serve as a sign that
points to a shared history and cultural
identity
because that history is fraught with
tension discrimination and violence
it's not surprising that aae is
considered a controversial topic
it is the most broadly studied variety
of american english
and has been the subject of many
high-profile court cases
over issues like school instruction and
linguistic profiling in employment and
criminal justice
attitudes of stigma and language
prejudice have forced many speakers of
aae to be bi-dialectal
able to speak both aae and whatever is
considered the mainstream norm of their
region
alternating between two different
dialects or languages or social
linguistic practices
is called code switching it can occur
casually
the way bilingual children of
spanish-speaking parents will transition
from english
to spanish back to english in one
sentence
but it can also be socially mandated
say if you speak in a formal register of
japanese with many honorifics when
addressing your boss
versus the more colloquial language you
may use with your pals
most speakers of aae are adept at
switching to mae based on context and
setting
like a job interview or other
professional situation
you want to make some money here use
your white boys my white voice
hey mr kramer this is langston from
regalview
but this skill is not without its
struggles having to constantly scan
social situations and adjust one's
speech patterns is a layer of extra
mental effort
that white speakers don't have to worry
about and speakers of aae may face
blowback from their own communities when
code switching
being accused of trying to sound white
you never want to be
the whitest sounding black guy in a room
there's also the question of why they
should have to change the way they speak
at all
just to make others more comfortable it
can be frustrating to know that
despite the linguistic evidence many
americans still hear aae as an inferior
or wrong version of mainstream american
english
and yet ironically aae is also one of
the most
copied and co-opted english dialects
some non-black speakers might use
features of the dialect to show
affiliation with african americans
or with traits they might
stereotypically associate with them
like confidence coolness or toughness
i know they don't mean any harm but they
don't realize how ignorant it is
trying to have that black voice that
some whites try to do yeah they really
don't do well
there are people like myself who do know
what they're saying and could do it i
think i honestly think i could
both american pop culture and youth
culture rely on
and are shaped by black cultural
practices products and behaviors
including music and language as these
cultural elements radiate outward from
urban centers to the rest of the world
slang expressions that originated in aae
are constantly being adopted by other
groups
groups that don't necessarily understand
the background
context and appropriate usage but enjoy
the social clout they bring
aae is a part of the cultural
inheritance of many african americans
and the strong sense of cultural
identity is also one of oppositionality
of embracing the contrast with other
groups and broader white society
the history that shaped aae has more
than its fair share of tragedy and
violence
the societal effects of which we are
still living with today
but the negative associations that many
people attach to aae
cause us to overlook the triumphs
perseverance
and creativity that gave african
american culture an
outsized role on the world stage
language
it turns out is more a reflection of the
overcoming of obstacles
than the obstacles themselves
do what what are you talking about i
think i could write for you in your
vernacular because of but what is my
vanilla well because i hang out with
yeah but what is my vernacular
what what are you talking about well
like this hug is all in my yoke
right dick what are you talking about